Bruce Wayne donned the cape and cowl to protect
his beloved Gotham City nearly a century ago.
Since then, he has become one of the most
popular superheroes the world has ever seen
— but that doesn't mean there weren't a
few hiccups along the way.
For example, while the Caped Crusader is now
famous for his no-killing rule, older versions
of the character were rather less strict.
Indeed, the early Batman terrorized, tortured,
and killed his enemies, proving a stark contrast
to the hero he later became.
1940's Batman #1 features one of Batman's
most brutal and shocking kills.
One of the issue's stories revolves around
the villainous Dr. Hugo Strange, who uses
a serum to transform a handful of asylum inmates
into mindless, destructive giants.
As they set out to wreak havoc on the streets
of Gotham, Batman tricks two of the giants
into beating each other to death.
He then tracks down a second giant and hangs
him from a noose dangling from his Batwing,
before using gas pellets to knock another
from the top of a skyscraper.
Incredibly, this isn't even Batman's most
brutal kill in those early days of Gotham
City, as arguably the most shockingly callous
of all can be found in the character's debut
story.
Batman first appeared in 1939's Detective
Comics #27, offering readers their first glimpse
of the man they would come to know as the
Dark Knight.
The story opens with Commissioner Gordon entertaining
his young friend, socialite Bruce Wayne, in
his home.
During their discussion, Gordon reveals that,
recently, he has become puzzled by a masked
vigilante known as the "Bat-man."
Soon after, Gordon is called to the murder
of a chemical manufacturer named Lambert,
and he offers to take his friend along for
the ride — Wayne accepts, of course, claiming
to have nothing better to do.
The police originally suspect the victim's
son, who says he pulled the knife from his
father's back when he found him and witnessed
a figure climb out the window.
The younger Lambert says his father's last
word was "contract" and tells the police that
his father had just entered into a contract
with three men: Alfred Stryker, Paul Rogers,
and Steven Crane.
While Gordon goes to see Crane, Bruce Wayne
returns home to put on his Batsuit — because
he's the Batman.
Bet you didn't see that coming.
"Holy masquerade!"
Unfortunately, Crane is already dead, although
Batman arrives at the scene just in time to
find his killers.
He knocks one out and then throws the other
off the top of a two-story building.
And while callously dropping someone from
30 feet up is bad enough, that's only the
second-worst thing Batman does to someone
in his debut story.
After tossing his foe off the roof, Batman
discovers that Paul Rogers and Alfred Stryker
are due to meet in Stryker's laboratory.
There, Stryker attempts to kill Rogers, but
Batman intervenes, pausing for just long enough
to explain Stryker's dastardly plan to take
control of the Apex Chemical Corporation.
Then, when Stryker pulls a gun to shoot them
both, Batman punches him so hard that he breaks
through a metal railing, falling into a vat
of acid.
When a surprised Rogers points out what's
happening, Batman callously comments that
it is a "fitting end for his kind."
Later, when Gordon tells the story to his
wealthy friend, Bruce Wayne, Wayne says it
all sounds like a "lovely fairy tale."
After that, the Dark Knight would kill again
multiple times, using fire, physical beatings,
and even guns to dispatch his foes.
In fact, the first few Batman stories in the
world of Detective Comics read more like a
full-blown rampage than a career in vigilantism.
As time went by, however, DC Comics decided
to pull Batman away from his pulp fiction
roots and make him more of a genuine superhero
— and that meant no killing.
By Batman #4, he was telling Robin never to
kill with weapons of any kind, and before
long the no-kill rule had become one of the
core tenets of Bruce Wayne's crime-fighting
philosophy.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
superheroes are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.